Hey everyone! We are going to kick off this ...
chapter by first taking a look at what goes into earning ...
income and the expenses associated with that.
We are going to do that by letting you take the center stage.
Here you are. You are ready for a new ...
chapter in life and you have decided to become a content ...
creator. You will use videos and ...
blogposts to make your business successful.
First, let's consider what goes into ...
your new venture.
You can use YouTube for free hosting but you need ...
good equipment to make solid content.
After doing some research you realize you need to ...
purchase new equipment that will cost $15,000.
Not bad since you can get a few years out of it.
Next you need a dedicated web page that will cost you ...
$250 per month for maintenance and security.
You plan on doing a bit of travelling to capture some ...
good spots, so you earmarked $30,000 for this.
Anything else? Sure!
There are some other expenses like insurance and ...
taxes you've accounted for. These total $10,000 for the year.
After 6 months of creating content you finally have 2,000 ...
subscribers to your content. You charge each of them $5 ...
per month for the remaining 6 months in the year.
You're also generating $2,000 in monthly income ...
from ads. So where are we?
First, lets get a few definitions out ...
of the way. The first is explicit cost.
These are costs that take on the form of a cash payment.
All the items you purchased go into this category.
This gives us a total of $58,000 for the year.
Next, is total revenue.
This is price times quantity. You have 2,000 subscribers ...
and you charge them each $5 per month,
so $10,000. You did this for 6 months,
so $60,000. You also generate revenue ...
from ads. So,
let's add the $12,000 from ad revenue to our total revenue.
We now have $72,000.
Next up is your accounting profit.
This is your total revenue minus your explicit costs.
This gives us $14,000 in net income. Not too bad!
But wait. There's more.
To go into this new venture you had to give up your prior ...
job where you made $45,000 per year.
You also have to dedicate all the space from a rental unit ...
that you earned an additional $12,000 per year.
These are what we call implicit cost,
that is income you earn once, but gave it up.
It's an opportunity cost. You could be earning ...
$57,000 instead you chose to do something else.
Now we can bring in the concept of an economic ...
profit. It's your total revenue minus ...
the total cost. You earned $72,000 in your ...
first year. You had an explicit cost of ...
$58,000 giving you an accounting profit of $14,000.
But you also had implicit cost of $57,000 because you gave ...
up what you could have been earning.
Now your economic profit is $72,000 - $115,000 or a ...
negative $43,000. This is called an economic loss.
In many cases this will cause a firm to either suspend ...
production or shut down altogether.
In your case may want to hang in there.
The last thing we want to mention it's what's called a normal profit.
This occurs when your economic profit is equal to 0.
In this case you have no incentive to deviate away ...
from your current business and go back to something ...
else. You also have a positive ...
accounting profit with a normal profit.
We'll be using this more in another chapter, so stay tuned.
Alright! That's it.
I hope you have enjoyed it and I'll see you in our next one.